hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that and my guest
today has been described as Germany's
leading illustrator all better still as
an international grand master of
illustration and here he is the Grand
Master in person Christoph me man great
to be here
that sounds good doesn't it grandma
Christoph Neiman's work has appeared in
many influential American publications
like the New York Times Wired magazine
and the New Yorker but also here in
Germany for instance in the prestigious
magazine supplement of deep sight
newspaper he's a man who can be very
funny and very serious and I'm sure he's
going to be a great guest Krista Waianae
I've had a wonderful wonderful week I
have to tell you because I've been going
I've been exploring your world the books
and the blogs and the apps in all the
little films and I've had moments of
laughter I've had tears yeah in my eyes
and I'm gonna put the tears aside for
just a moment to begin with the laughter
I'd like to ask you how important humor
is to you you were extremely important
and not necessarily because I think Oh
laughing is healthy it's a fantastic
communication device I think it allows
us to tell a story to connect go beyond
expectations because though the whole
idea of humor is to can i disappoint
expectations to set every joke is set up
you have a certain kind of situation
that causes a certain expectation and
then you mess with that in an absurd a
funny weird way and I think that's often
how you can actually break through to a
reader
mm-hmm you're describing how who you are
and what you do and the impact you try
to have I introduced you at the
beginning of the show as an illustrator
is that enough does that suffice as a
job description for you it on the one
hand it definitely describes what I
would I do it has definitely broadened
in the last couple of years I'm not
gonna like lose sleep over like my job
description it definitely has changed in
that regard that I used to illustrate a
lot of articles where I had to put in my
two cents in what I did but where
ultimately might have
was to make something else I can given
topic shine one way or another and it
has changed and so far that now I'm
reading more into storytelling and also
generating the content I'm saying like
this is the story that I want to tell so
in terms of the tools that I use it's
still very much the same constantly
evolving but in terms of the the actual
assignments it's more assignments that
come out of myself and let's talk a
little bit about your mood while your
work is it's interesting I've talked
about tears and I've talked about
laughter and with you I have the sense
that there are two mood polls and one of
them is agony and one of them is ecstasy
and you sort of swing between the two
and there's not an awful lot in between
well it's like a 95 percent swing to the
agony and only like a five percent swing
to the because ultimately I feel that
the ecstasy is like what the reader
supposed to experience or the fun or the
the laughter and my job is to make it
maybe look like it was done in fun and
ecstasy but sadly in my experience in
order to make something look effortless
it takes an awful lot of effort and just
to follow up with that thought there's
one there's one wonderful quote from you
I really liked it very very much indeed
indeed creativity is like chasing
chickens can you follow through on that
thought it's already thought really
comes from Rocky one from that moment
when when Rocky is practicing in the
coaches like here just catched a chicken
something that looks relatively not only
easy but all only a almost like denying
it turns out to be not only incredibly
hard but also extremely unsexy really
it's not like a grand like running
through the mountains are lifting a
gigantic rock it's just it looks pretty
desperate and the problems the second
problem is you can't do like half an
effort you have to go all the way
because like that chicken is not gonna
give you half a leg if you kind of run a
little too slow unless you can I go full
throttle there's no chance for success I
have to ask you have you ever chased the
chicken in real life I have not shaken
anything but maybe we seemed real enough
that I fell they can draw that
conclusion I can boast that I have
chased the chicken successful
I have mentioned that you are more
successful I think it's fair to say
you're very very very successful in the
US and slightly less well-known here in
Germany that's ironic and it demands an
explanation it might just be because of
your you know the way you've lived your
life so far and it might have something
to do with with the way your trade is
seen here in Germany and seen in the US
it probably has something to do with
just like the amount of work that I'm
capable of doing and I could get more
and more requests here in Germany the
problem is I only have so many hours in
the day and so many collect mental
capacities that I can only fill so many
pages with with things I have worked in
the state's a lot longer and I have some
clients that I continue to work there
for so obviously my drawings probably
are better known there it's starting to
slowly change and of course with the
internet and everything things blend
when I do something for The New Yorker
people see it here as well and I
definitely think that that's actually
gonna accelerate in the coming years
that this idea of working for one
country or one cultural entity is less
or less and less relevant
Stephani mandersohn we're gonna go back
to your early days now and the story
goes that when you were I don't know
what three four years old you said I
want pencils I asked for pencils I don't
think I had to fight too hard I think my
parents were more than willing to kind
of pass them on to me and my brother
your brother yeah it's interesting that
you mentioned him because I read that he
was that he was the more talented one
initially with the pencils in question
well I I was I asked for them I started
it and he was ton better than me which I
found weed he said I think I was like
the harder worker eventually said oh it
is like ongoing struggle that's one of
the themes of your life I find sort of
perseverance hard work staying focused
ya know on the one hand it's some
sometimes I feel I deserve to have more
fun when I work I have a great job so
why can I just go to work everyday and
have a jolly good time on the other hand
of course it makes it actually more
predictable in a sense that if you can't
connect breakthrough you know the only
the only way you can get there is you
just try harder and eventually it's
gonna happen which in a one somehow is
like more it's nicer to know that
there's that way rather than waiting for
the golden moment where the thing just
drops muscat okay so when you were
younger yeah I want to go back to you
being a youngster maybe a teenager yeah
you may or may not have been fascinated
and I don't know what rock bands the
kind of conventional thing that
teenagers are interested in were you
also did you have illustrators who you
were already looking to emulate I
started with Tomi Angharad a fantastic
French children's book author I went to
Asterix and Obelix when I was like five
- I would say 1011 yeah and then went
all out Mad Magazine for probably a
solid decade with I would say Don Martin
and Mort Drucker who did the movie
spoofs as my client golden heroes okay
and so you you were good at school I
gather yeah on TV that you were good at
school yeah in the town of vine blingin
that I've never visited oh that's where
I was born or grew up a few miles
through the woods there okay Annie
by is the city of Stuttgart you went to
art college in the city of Stuttgart and
that was extremely input you didn't go
far here but you you were tutored by
somebody called Heinz Edelman a bit of a
legend quite a bit of a legend he's
sorry for the art direction of the
drawings for Yellow Submarine the
Beatles movie that's an iconic sir there
was actually something that he almost
like this owned he's done like a huge
amount of fantastic book cover work
poster work illustration and design work
that is like among like when I came to
New York for the first time people are
like oh the great Heinz either man which
definitely didn't hurt so he was really
quite quite a legend hmm he went off to
do that was the Nets the next step in
your journey first of all you went to
Stuttgart not very far then you went to
New York you didn't know anybody in New
York and you were travelling very light
I was travelling very light I had my
portfolio and I had a bag of quarters
and I was really I had written letters
but ultimately it was like standing at a
Grand Central Station at one of these
payphones not really understanding what
they were saying because my English was
too bad and the connection was really
bad and then just like hoping that we're
all going means yes come by next Tuesday
and show us your book tell us about your
initial successes because that must have
been very that must have been very very
exciting for you you go go you go to a
completely new country you have to
understand in a new mentality to be able
to comment on it to be able to
illustrate life there and you were
successful well it was fantastic the
first time you have a drawing published
of course is an incredible moment I was
still an intern and I got a call from
Rolling Stone a fantastic art director
Fred Woodward at the time who said we do
this record review for me and they sent
me the CD and I listened to the CD and
there was really it was all about yeah
yeah baby yes I didn't really have
anything to go on
I was absolutely desperate I actually
made a final overnight like then made a
sketch off the final sent that in
because I was too afraid my sketch
wouldn't work out and they said yeah no
sure it's fine and I assumed I mean it's
terrible and we assigned somebody else
and then I ended up in bacon stood curd
I ended up running to the international
bookstore every week
just freaking out and then three weeks
later it was actually in there there was
a pretty special moment wonderful
absolutely wonderful good for you now
let's but let's make a great big leap
forward to a little bit more closer to
what you're doing now let's have a look
at some images from one of your most
recent projects called petting zoo yeah
we'll have a look at those and then
maybe you can tell us a little bit about
what we're saying crystal so this is an
interactive app called Pegasus and the
idea behind it was I sometimes look at
drawings and you I felt like what if you
could just like touch the drawing into
drawing would be something and that was
the plan behind this the problem was
that as I started working on it I
thought there must be an application for
this there must be something where just
feed my drawings into and say connect
tap or swipe right and then it will
connect trigger the movements there
wasn't so the first step in this what I
found at the end being a very creative
crotchet was just sitting there typing
endless lines of code of numbers and
letters and commas into the computer
which was difficult to say to put it
mildly you've always been very open to
it you know what I mean he's cold in the
cliche a mixed media approach from your
very early days really no I was very
open it was never really an excitement
for media per se it was never oh there's
a computer there's great filters how can
that influence my work I always saw it
as wow there's a piece of technology and
now I can do that thing that I always
dreamed of and I can do it cheaply
faster more perfectly I think I spent 10
years of my youth just trying to do flat
color I wanted to have like a black
outline filled with red and it never
works like no matter what market you use
it's always cloudy or weird or imperfect
and when the computer came along bling
you have to like perfect red flat and
it's all today it's it's similar with
this app where where I found I always
wanted to do this kind of project and
now I have the tools and the
possibilities to do it with very like
very few resources hmm something else
that you've been doing which is
extremely interesting was actually a
work that was given to President Barack
Obama
when he came here to Germany on his
state visit earlier this summer I think
we can we can have a look at that I
think and just tell us a little bit
about that because that's fascinating
yeah this is this is a print I did and I
got a call from the chief of protocol
from the president's office on the
morning when when Barack Obama was
supposed to arrive in the morning on the
very moon when the very morning and they
were like oh we're not quite happy with
the with with the presents that we have
so far and do you have something there
and I looked through my through my flat
files and I saw that post and I felt
that it on the one hand it was something
really about kind creativity in New York
but I felt it's actually quite a nice
metaphor for diplomacy and the
difficulties and how sometimes the
difficult situation might actually end
up in a good way interesting now that
leads us along very nicely because when
Barack Obama last visited Germany was
this summer I just mentioned it the mood
between Berlin and Washington was I
think it's fair to say still amicable
much though has happened since then
revelations and more revelations that
the American security services have been
gathering all sorts of information on
German citizens and even spied on
Chancellor Angela Merkel well it's left
many people here in Germany wondering
how much they can trust a country that
is meant to be one of this country's
closest allies
there's a big problem here yeah how
would you define the problem well on the
one hand of course it's a problem of
trust and really friendship between
countries and what you can and cannot do
legally in terms of international
treaties the the aspect that freaks me
out probably more than the idea of
wiretapping
Merkel or not is is really global
implication is this there were some
reactions on the American side after
this that concept like a come on guys
everybody does it don't be Neve yeah
real good real mmm-hmm which also I
almost found like added a little bit of
a kind of bring it on quality is like
you know if you were good enough to do
this with us he would you would do it as
well that was what I read is connected
at the sub line and that I found
incredibly dangerous and stupid because
I think ultimately especially America
will always depend there will be
situations where America will depend on
the good will of the people to make
really tough international political
decisions and these will be the moments
where this kind of behavior will come
back to haunt not them but all of us I
think and that's something where I feel
it's not really worth doing all these
things to hurt a much much larger cause
and that is something that worries me
more even though everything that the NSA
is doing there is really worrisome but
that's like a larger thing that I think
will be a long and sadly interesting
story you're clearly worried and and and
and I am too I would have it on a very
personal level by these developments I'm
wondering whether if I retrace your
development that we went through your
develop a little bit you will I guess
you were living in New York at the time
of the 9/11 attacks on New York and
elsewhere does that shape your under
does that give you a greater insight
into the into the pattern that is
emerging here the way that America felt
attacked has felt attacked and has
responded I I doubt it would would
really mean that I have a larger
understanding strangely for me I was
there I had just married my wife was
pregnant at the time so it was a very
very personal moment
it was very intense and for me it was
almost more like oh now I understand
what like my the older generation in
Europe was always talking about thank
you seeing standing there knowing you're
vulnerable and also knowing I was in the
city my studio was like half a mile up
from Ground Zero okay that was for me
they meant me when they did that me
personally not me theoretically and it
changes your worldview but it doesn't
like these moments in New York were
actually these weeks afterwards even in
America when there were demonstrations
in Tehran like pro-american
demonstrations they were politically
actually really fascinating and as much
as in a situation something can be
beautiful these were actually beautiful
moments of coming together and it
started turning weird like months later
where you realized like the strong big
political gears came into motions and
like the government at the time we
trying to kind fulfill an agenda that
had nothing to do with that based on
these events and I think ever since it's
hard to kind of separate the two I think
that the the whole terrorism threat is
real and it will be a lot of like most
of it will probably be with computers
and with collective we attacking water
plans from a laptop yeah and that's why
I think there the fact that there's an
NSA is probably justified interesting
thoughts yeah
let's change gear just a slight little
bit because we're talking you there are
two cities in your life for that moment
we've had Stuttgart and that area that
you come from originally but you live in
Berlin you used to live in New York
let's talk about your relationship to
New York you did something very very
interesting you you run in the I think
it was the 2011 marathon yeah and I
don't quite know how we got some images
for what you did and maybe you can
explain to me what is going on because I
find it totally bewildering in fact
there we go christoph i had watched the
marathon we as a spectator in new york
and i found it to be like the most
emotional sports moment that i ever
experienced and i thought i once in my
life i want to run it and I felt the
perfect excuse to run it is if I turn it
into a job and the most quite insane way
of turning this into a job was to
actually draw it while running it so I
did draw
while you were running I draw I drew
when I was walking everything had to be
in motion it was very important I ran
thought about an idea then it would slow
down to a walking pace but actually
doing all the writing and drawing while
I was while I was walking so have you
you were doing the drawings you were
actually taking a photo of the drawings
yes you were and then uploading them to
Twitter mm-hmm to need to be very real
and social media and it was fascinating
to like afterwards kinda see the
reaction and then like as I can I
progressed in the race more and more
people knew who I was at the beginning
was they oh look there's somebody
writing a book and at the end people
actually knew oh he's the guy
illustrating and I know you're I know
you're pretty fit I know you you run
here in Berlin quite regularly and
there's somebody who runs a bit and has
run a marathon in my time yeah I'm
curious are you gonna share with us the
the time you ran while you were doing
all this stuff I did six hours ten when
I did that I ran a little faster when I
only render a cij I want to get the kind
of competition part out of this and
really only I actually assumed that at
the end I would like kind of ride over
the finish line with the bus that you
know takes all the kind of people who
don't quite make it okay now we're gonna
talk about something very different now
something called synesthesia it's a
neurological condition sometimes
described as a blending of the senses so
somebody with synesthesia might hear a
certain piece of music and it puts a
certain taste in their mouth or perhaps
more commonly they might see a certain
color and then they'll see at the same
time a letter of the alphabet now
Kristoff can tell us more about this
shortly knows much more about it than I
do
I definitely know about this idea of
connecting colors to letters and numbers
mm-hmm something I ever had always had I
had discussions with my brother I said
it is all viously dark green and he
would say no it's red I was like this is
absolutely not true and the problem
ultimately for creative work of course
is it doesn't really have that much of
an impact because it's a very personal
and it's a very personal thing my in my
world letters and numbers are connected
with colors but if I told you if I
showed you like a B that's orange you
wouldn't laugh about because you
probably don't know that a beat is
supposed to be blue as it is if I were
to say if I'm either I mean if we were
to spend time - if we were to meet on a
train for example and we were to chat
with each other for two hours would I
notice in that time that you are some
you are synesthetic yeah I doubt it and
I think we're at this point we probably
all are and we all art we're all trained
to be synesthetic when when you look at
the logo of a brand when you drink a
certain drink you think of the logo or
like even with phones when you have
phone from a certain telecom provider
they will like have their certain jingle
so we're actually I think by now it's
really like part of like the the media
world took like they have this whole
universe of sound and image and visuals
that it's supposed to they're supposed
to give us an idea of that thing that
we're supposed to love and buy mm-hmm
I'm just I'm really fascinated by how
you see yourself in the situation
because what age did you realize aha
there's something about me I mean you're
saying that you know we're all to an
extent synesthetic but I'm not that I
don't know for me it was it was never a
question then especially like the
connection from letters and numbers to
colors so when I thought of a number I
thought okay our home number is purple
green grey blue really and that actually
helped me remember numbers or names and
sometimes even if I wouldn't really
remember the name I would still know it
was clay in the greenish blue area and
then I knew it could not be George
because there would be red and white
that's absolutely fascinating have you
got a good memory
decent it really failed me at times I
hope it's practicing also appreciation
practices a little more because he were
you know when I was reading up on the
subject and trying to find out you know
what it's all about it was said that not
only does it run in families but that
people the people like you have
generally speaking have excellent
memories a great resource efficient was
more prevalent we've talked about we've
talked about in New York we've talked
about Berlin you made the choice what
four five years ago to kill five years
ago to come from New York to Berlin why
did you make that choice it I did not
want to do it for the kids because I
always felt when you do something for
the kids it's something that eventually
if you don't like it you might always go
like oh and everybody of course always
goes like obviously you did that for the
family for me having moved from German
to New York was an incredibly scary but
also energizing move like to go into a
different culture into a different city
is something that's very confusing but
it rewires you almost and eventually I
had this decision with my wife to say
let's do this again she also she's
German she moved to New York we met
there and we both said we want to have
another moment in our life where we are
slightly disoriented and be in a new
place having to completely reinvent
ourselves mhm and also see what to see
what that does with my work whether like
the different environment in Berlin
would would can change my approach
something like it's less like perfection
oriented here then I would see it in New
York that's interested we'll talk about
that in just a second because that is a
very interesting aspect of that decision
that you made I know now there's no
doubt about it if you're going to
experiment Berlin is a good place to do
it Berlin is booming and it's drawing in
people in all sorts of creative sectors
just like Christoph Neiman now many of
them don't want to be stuck on their own
of course they want to be rubbing up
against other creative types so what
they do is they join what is called and
here's one of those great big long
German words a bureau or Gemeinschaft
which is the German word for office
sharing
you work in an in a shared office
situation but you don't exactly have
three people at three desks in one room
or anything like that you're not not
quite I used to work by myself there
it's a given you start out you just like
working essentially in your bedroom and
I've always found it perfectly efficient
the problem is I always started working
with E in my underpants and t-shirt and
then you just kind of skip breakfast you
start to like work and you find yourself
at 2:00 o'clock in the afternoon still
being like it's in social habits bad
social habits but the bigger problem I
realized was I would be on important
phone calls and particularly in that
place I had to sit underneath my desk
because the phone reception was better
down there so I had this conference call
with the coming a group of people in
California in California and I had to
talk about like the creative vision for
the company or something and I'm sitting
there in underpants under my desk under
cables and I realized that this tension
from the image I tried to project into
my actual physical situation right now
can I created some personal attention
and that eventually I might have to find
a situation where I'm fully dressed with
a cup of coffee walking somewhere saying
good morning to people and that might be
beneficial to me so I changed that very
soon after you came to Berlin you said
we need to go back to that point because
you wanted to learn new tricks that was
one quote I saw what sort of new tricks
have you learned while it was also like
the the the idea from not doing too many
tricks because when you're in a place
like New York where everything's
deadline efficiency you don't start a
book and then you don't finish it
everything so you become very good about
seeing problems before they happen
navigating around them and the new
tricks was we need to just like take a
mistake or a problem head-on and just
see what happens if I do something where
I'm actually not sure whether I can
finish it or not that's interesting
you're talking about or certainly the
way New York is perceived from outside
as being this very busy buzzy place New
York has a buzz there's no doubt about
that Berlin has a buzz yeah which city
has the bigger buzz I do can judge well
no I think they're both a little too big
and too diverse fortunately in order to
really change that
which one has the bigger buzz I found
New York to be a place that's just so
high-strung in a really fantastic sense
that if you want to get something done I
in my experience there's no better place
than that I think it can be a little
stifling eventually because you're so
busy producing and getting things done
and avoiding to make mistakes that
sometimes I find it difficult to
replenish your kind of creative tank and
dad was maybe the biggest goal with the
move here that's interesting okay let's
change it we don't have that much time
left and we like to ask our guests here
on the show to bring along a treasured
possession or something that is it you
know physically interesting for you and
you've you've made a very unusual choice
I have to say yeah no this is explain
Krista this is a hammer of a piano and
well I know technically what a hammer
looks like I started playing the piano
five months ago I used to always play a
little bit yeah but I now I have a piano
teacher I go to a music school and I
have half an hour a week where I learn
to read from score and it's incredibly
hard but what it has allowed me is to
really like to have time off have mental
time off because when I read or when I
run when I draw I always think about
other things when I play the piano it's
so incredibly difficult and I'm so
terribly bad at it that there's no room
for any other thought and so I've found
that extremely liberating the problem
came when really demanded a vanity mixes
in and likes now I'm sitting there at
night playing the piano and I had a
glass of wine but you're not supposed to
put on the piano as I learned I did and
of course it fell into a moment of
beautiful cultural self image just like
fell apart and it was like taking the
piano apart within minutes and then with
q-tips like trying to clean that's when
I realize you can take a piano apart
actually quite easily that tells us an
awful lot about the kind difficulty in
the earth thank you for that Thank You
mr. Ashley forbidden to have any food or
drinks near the piano we're gonna wrap
up now with our traditional talking
Germany quiz at the end of the the show
them I'll give you two to choose from
yeah
Berlin cool or New York hip neither for
me neither
you reject the concept completely and
utterly running or walking running
running yeah you run twice a week here
in Berlin I know yeah
if there were a global election would
you vote for Barack Obama or Angela
Merkel I while considering that they
represent a grand total of 8 % of the
world population probably and I think
neither of them would be a good choice
at this point
Merkel might be a little bit more
popular in a global scale but have made
art or digital art ultimately always
handmade I made yeah despite your
fascination for Hansel on paper or the
ink on paper which is still the greatest
thrill and nothing else will top that
are your kids your biggest fans or your
biggest critics depending on their mood
and we're gonna come full circle what's
more important to you getting people to
laugh or getting people to think
thinking a still greater achievement
that is your lot with the entertaining
and philosophical Christoph Lehmann
others more talking Germany including my
blog and our archived on our website you
might also like to watch the German
version of the show that's to push
Tydfil thio Schumacher for now bye bye